Ok let's just hope to have to start again. Well so we had an old man name is dismissed who was about to retire.
And he decided he'd buy the smallest post office he could find and retire.
So of course he bought the neiman post office and ended up here in the heyday.
When the town was starting to brew
and he would get the most ridiculous letters addressed to people like rain in the treehouse tenable falls
and he by the end of it he was quite speer he could very high blood pressure. He was really quite betty.
And one morning i remember walking into the post office and he was throwing a tantrum.
And he had hold someone across the counter by the shirt collar and was. You know. Screaming abuse at them.
And he had another man that worked for him and i know who was. He was so mild mannered and me.
Made me just check the wobblies
and all that kind of looks don't face that you know one day i said to know how you deal with it you know i couldn't
stand it. And he said i'll wait until it's no and around i go ahead on to the back step. And not piss me so full of.
The coming days ago it was very going to the post-office and.
Cross the counter and he says them back to mrs smith retired and sold it to another.
Poor unfortunate man who now gets abused.
The other day when i was being abused by some very out of it looking character. And that's quite a while wrist.
It's like at the very center. It seems to be cyclic.
To you know desire is it's just gorgeous and you couldn't ever imagine. She think.
To seriously consider the direction where you can go from here. Especially when your friends got so bored.
It's called the hundred word story. Like.
Oh yes when we first started the rainbow cafe it wasn't as it appears to this day i had little room.
That was still you know had their panties and things.
And every saturday we would have to vacate one of these little rooms at the back in the sky. Coming.
Plug his phone in and go in when we realized what he was jane because he's trying to keep us locked down
but we were just to use him and. I've been don't pretend to own the place but there is no excuse made.
I want to get changed
and things like this because if we store some have to back it from another part of the back door
and then some by the facilities were fairly skin was very good from a local bike and.
He was the local baker who became very very wealthy. From having. A lot of the land around here.
After he was a bakery sell the baker. Bakery and they became a real estate agent cleaned up. And then moved.
Thank you very much kelly. Oh yeah yeah. Well.
We don't know that it was really i think it's like it's hard for me to see that he went to the bakery on here
and baker. Only lived here and so during the increased festival the people from the female foundry.
Gave him a recipe for life which became their careers.
And he liked that and sold it all around the area each time the bakery has been sold. That recipe is part of the deal.
I think they change it every time and change hands that doesn't really resent. Anything like the night.
But it was all made me go you got me. Organic grains and it was very tasty. As it was pretty primitive.
Yeah it was very primitive and closing down at pisa and ensuing the best you could do is for shelter goddess. Here.
I lived in a cabin else that had on one side the front of it was just a garden and.
We had holidays and a big cast on tap outside. No more in the actual house.
And it would start if it was totally an enclosed so it not. In the winter was very cold and.
That was where my second child was born and we lived there for a couple of years before we moved to another community.
And i was not impressed. And was a banshee i think that's a fairly have to scription. Chuck wobblies regularly.
Well the plates. Tell him i don't want to live like this is not what i was cut out for at all.
Having children it wasn't as difficult for me. And i quite enjoyed that.
I mean it's like just continuing the playhouse aspect of my childhood home
and being in north queensland to have a very different climate
and ways to make these amazing ways to call them plastic palaces. With a staple gun builders plastic trays on his age.
In queensland. So that was different when we were here during the festival.
It was often very cold in the only place you could buy it was in the kraken hits the back of bands out the back of the
right. Things like tropical also. Her problem.
A lot of people used to get really really bad tropicals is that basically that was because hygiene was difficult
and change a change of lifestyle tends to bring things in and also the paspalum when it cedes.
I don't know why that is such a sticky standing stuff and it gets stuck to skin
and often if there was a little cattle graze there. And up with a tropical sun and you would say.
And i think partly it was diet as well people maybe going from being made to make purely vegetarian
and not getting the right protein and. Yeah. And often not enough food.
Little and good food
and one of my dear friends was pregnant at the time to this weight on her shoe i think it was six weeks before the
births used to get twenty five dollars a fortnight. And i was a smoker i'm quite a heavy smoker and.
She stood by me a packet of drama out of that money.
Every week every fortnight if she could it wasn't every fortnight actually. And we would go to listen to the you.
I the u.p.i. Rooms. Which was like country women's association food. And we'd have. Corned beef and.
You know what source and.
And putting it was a real civil rights and to see to the table you know with a cloth an offer for the big tree and.
Yeah the single women around here that run pensions for a very popular.
Thing that would be a whole household centered around this not a single parent should have to tell stories of that
other tangible. Did you stay because that you couldn't get social security but there was no.
You know the single mothers would get. I think it was the forth community. That i lived.
Living on a community where there's so many different ways that it can be done. Robert.
I would say one of the most successful ones because the land was already owned by someone.
There was no necessity to just take any camera. To who had money to buy a share.
So we managed to step aside very slowly with.
Extended family often brothers and sisters brothers and brothers mothers and children. So it's friends and friends.
Yeah. You had to sort of. You have to really. And it works. Because we was real strong communication between everybody.
A big extended family. Was from the normal entrepreneurial in the entrepreneurial.
I mean places like which people that live a ton of them i imagine has its ups and downs.
Because you don't get to choose your neighbors but once again tangibles very established
and a lot of those people have known each other for a really really time.
So there's a very strong contingent of old friends that i would say counterbalances the adverse.
Things that happen when you don't have any choice about who you live with.
And i don't think westerns are very good at that.
And i think we're very basic i think we're communal animals we're very territorial and.
So i don't really really feel though i think. Feel economically.
Communities work i don't think in the in the real sense. People tend to isolate themselves and pushing off.
This is mine and. You know if you stop in my vegie patch over here but it's no natural.
It's not that sort of training really. If you don't you know you know you're occasionally is really good.
And communicate. And the indians do it so much better.
Yes better human a man living in close proximity with one another because a lot of the communities they stays out run
in the sense of.
An equal share like i mean people even these days have their own title
and they have a portion of land that is theirs that they can put a fence around if they want to so really they're not
all. Communities some of them are fine subdivisions cost. Rule accommodation for people so. In one sense they're vital.
I don't put them down a tall. Though i wouldn't choose to live like that so.
Because it's come full circle other people's needs to be able to resell. Yeah economically.
Because it is difficult on our community we cannot sell it and we don't you know. Constitution.
It's the company that owns everything.
And so we have that's us to sell it so we have to be sure that our relationships are very good if you want to go
somewhere. You don't go. Living in a screaming hate. You actually leave. Fairly i mean really and.
You have other things that you have to do so you do.
Community organizers who they want to live in your house and that person reimburses you
but your shares are totally nonrefundable
and that's the deal with all of us agreed to that because their shares are incredibly reasonably priced in his own in a
small number of them. Dress. Very much indeed. But we built on trust because we didn't have any tenure told.
In the beginning when we built there. And the woman on the land is one a very extraordinary human being so.
We trusted her. And she trusted. Yes and it's worked really well. But that's just like you really feel like that.
Changes here. My god my god. We don't really need to discuss. The drug problem. Everybody else.
You know that's it said. Changes. The town. Ease. Like we've noticed in the last two years particularly that.
Things are going here it is expanding. I mean to the point where we don't have parking. Anymore.
In the street it's a battle to even. You know.
There's lots of new businesses that have opened and they seem to be sustaining themselves out. Well.
And we are accused of having become more straight. I think and. Whatever that means.
I think that there are many more people who were originally a craze people that have decided to make a livelihood.
But most of those people that i know make it out of something they really enjoy doing.
So i don't necessarily see that as yeah i see it and also i think their value system. They have kept it.
Why back there we tend to throw a few babies that with a head to go and sort of start to sleep bring them back
and say sorry yes you were right mom and dad. Society story behind this. But in the long term.
We did throw a lot of bathwater out that was really good to get rid of.
But we do have to survive you know we do have to leave and we have to face that.
And look at society you think it's ok i would try and feed him. And. As much on the terms as possible.
Was a bit possibly the aquarian ideas were the beginning of the green movement.
I mean
when i talked about in a sense that's the best thing it for a revolution i'm truly believe that the ecological movement.
Is the revolution. I mean. There was no way that society was just going to collapse.
But they an extraordinary amount of waste. That we produce as a race.
If we didn't have the green movement where the heck would we be having me like the watchdog. Taken.
Twenty years for it to get any momentum at all or any training years ago we were sitting down crying about it.
Day in and and totally impotent and didn't know what to do but could see it and.
People were talking about it in real terms back then. If you had these to hear it. And nothing was done and.
Twenty years down the track. And that's why i sometimes catch myself thinking it's too late and crying and.
I think it's really difficult. But it does seem to have a bit of a hold now. It's moving ahead.
And people are becoming conscious of it.
And we've done it again we've done that in a real fun with a friend who dresses up as an old lady who goes to
supermarkets with born to shop bags and. Badges you know.
And she just advise everyone superman what's the best things to ryan has a great time doing it goes off to all the
markets and i'm celeste. She's the only steel shop at best. But i think also that. First protesters.
Protests that we had a really mini area where they were that all money from a lot of. Subsequent movements and.
At the time. There was the biggest uproar about the hippies telling the bloggers what to do. I mean we were.
The confrontations that some of those the terrain one in particular i remember was. Horrible.
I mean you know people being hold of trees and.
It was not that really broke new ground and really dated and it has made a very big.
It's made people more courageous about speaking up for what they believe in
and chaining themselves to trees if they feel that that's necessary.
So i do believe that the aquarius movement not just the aquarius festival but. That whole period in time.
This was the beginning of that.
Of any real changes that was like if you got a little bit on the rear
and a funny one i carry out tell you about being in jail. I can see. This is the being in power. Now.
But it was it was it was fun center. We had this outcome. God can have to tell always awful things.
We have the so can old holden called luigi. Restrained in the time. That.
Jim and i had bought from a friend of us called robbie in sydney.
We're supposed to pay my hundred dollars we paid in twenty.
Neither of us had a license and we left sydney are back to i am so we wouldn't have any traffic
or time we got to hornsby. It would already last second gear. So we went up and we arrived at my parents' place.
On route. To name and were coming to newman to work.
A festival and provided all the questions about the legalities of the space that we had and. Then we came here.
And we were at the story is about. I am driving down to the beach town past bonding with a chord progression hate.
When we went there and there's a caravan park there anyway so we packed luigi there. And we went down to the basij and.
The tide came in so we were able to swim around a couple of beaches. A-y. From the current.
And as we come out of north queensland we've been running naked for a couple of years already off with the clothes
and then we went for a good swim.
And i must tell you joe was nearly nine months pregnant with jean king at this point in time.
So she was for every being round and round these huge breasts is renowned for it. And her blue eyes.
In case this got be close to a day focus from her beautiful blue eyes. Originally. Anyway so.
We'd have a swim and jill and i was sitting on the beach and we could see a gardener and miss campbell fishing and.
And he was he went past and he climbed up was like you got trial over the mountain and back around the cabin.
And then there was nobody you know. And then looked up. And here are two people think sman.
Coming well to maintain her place and coming down over the hill.
So we sort of had a little discussion i want to do and thought of. We'll just stay put it's ok.
Surely if i could handle. We're sitting down you know it's not much to say and. And jewels when seen having swim and.
These men walked right up to us and we thought oh that's really insensitive you know now what. And i said.
My place get your clothes on girlie. You know.
And i'm certain to jewels come out of the water come out of the water
and she's saying you know what was going are you know. Anyway so.
Jill stood up to sort of get it close only just looked at this.
Figure you know up until then they were just looking at mason come on girl you know i get your clothes.
And i said are you pregnant and she said.
Do you think watermelon being really cheeky to them
but i would just sing them my school ludicrous thing which of course of course i mean.
Apparently the fisherman had told the guy at the caravan park and the guy at the caravan. Heighted he peace.
He rang the police thinking this is a good.
You know this is a good one and said i had to walk like a nine kilometer or something over this track to get us anyway.
So i knew i had by this time jules this realize that something's going on so i called and said come and get a close on.
So we did it in a sort of a fashion and. We had to follow them one walked in front and behind and off we went and.
Trying to communicate with each other because we didn't want i didn't want to acknowledge that we had this bloody can't.
Because none of us have that sense right and there's a little bit of something or other in the glove box plus all
and i know sooner or later than. You know i just all asked if our whole life was in bloody luigi poor thing. So drunk.
Clunking our car passed me just of my little wife and we went on
and so they put us in the place come to us to the station. And they actually had to ring up to find out what.
Charge us with. So i went for the criminal charge which was offensive behavior. And we were fingerprinted and searched.
And i had to search out belongings and. I had a certain belonging that. Really i didn't like looking at.
Now i told them they wouldn't. And i had no.
Woman there so you know one of the place
and had together twelve i mean it was just crazy they could have just say no we're not going to answer this call
but they obviously wanted to make a stand and it was something that people were being offended by.
At that point in time.
Most of the people without clothes on no matter how far away you went from everybody it was just an issue.
So we got locked up.
But we still told them that you would be very upset if she was locked in a cell and might bring on her birth.
So i didn't even dare and i looked at some just out. Exercise yard. So went like this not gone.
Like songs with a funny thing about the winter that was really cute i learned that song and.
I bought us some fish and chips because we were vegetarians and. Wholemeal bread fruit.
And by then we rang graham and term. The aquarius foundation by old us.
So later santa may while i can still around the bay. Didn't have a bible. Thank god.
But we had to go to court you know that whole thing. And the whole of name been turned up at the court.
Which of course didn't do any good for us in the morning but it's made it much worse. And the other thing was that.
That morning we had to get to court so we had to steal it.
So we stole his car and left a note on the footpath under a rock sign.
But we just had to take your car to get out because so when we got back in his car the police called us up
and said this coast guard i mean that was ok of course as soon as we found him
and saved our see that we had to go to court and. It was like that you know. It's just it was a funny.
I'm very interested you said. Oh yes. We were guilty.
But i was yes i am and find us were all fined fifty dollars over ten days
and nobody was going to do ten days so we were promised we would give him fifty dollars. Ok. I am just those of us.